oh my god they'll idiots yes yep yep
they're all die don't really don't I
really wanna look off you all but you're
really stupid
yeah we're not leaving we're all
sticking together together
yeah no matter what we us to hell oh you
know what he's having a megacrisis
what's gone off in a tangent and decided
he's gonna be that guy this is good I'm
feeling musty what I don't wanna do it
if it makes the [ __ ] hero you just
ran off and blow up the building by
himself
it's like yeah [ __ ] Nathan Drake just
wasn't even in there George wasn't even
there
why didn't you see that problem with
sanatoria that I'll go sort this [ __ ]
out you guys stay here
so Dom you're like oh I'm just mad I'm
mad at them I'm mad at them so I feel
like this must be what it's like to be a
parent who's like trying to look after
their kids and the kids just keep making
really [ __ ] dumb choices oh my god
yes I'm gonna point that it's too
obvious the room makes me like nuts and
we can to get it down I think up is the
only way to go I'm sorry but Dan is not
good
no she just go back yeah yeah they
should just go back yeah
Chris what you doing it's going to be
the lira he's really slowly like he
didn't actually wanna be in there he
wanted to go back because he's like
slowing them down because he hurt
himself and I didn't want him
certainly yes
I hope not Jesus I'm saving the mines
yeah thank you people this game unlike
two locations like Des Moines
long-sleeve mines something I enjoy
des moines a message and the tower that
good yeah
talent is now defunct hot Moines
basically also mine we should have
shower getting ballistic lip love yeah
she's pretty boy it's progressive yeah
yeah close it I are done yes close it
yes are you doing it myself
close it close it okay
Pleasant cuz then is to copy they don't
even watch
well are they bearing their friggin
blood the others on so I don't want to
catch those guys so that what are they
looking good oh you actually yeah you
don't know me that way it's not oh my
god
completely the only way they can be
seriously why by yourself
Ashley I hate all of you you're also Dom
you once my job you might sit there
until don't run over to the [ __ ]
sanatorium when you don't you know you
wanna let then by going there because
this lights up a hit
oh my god these idiots pack of idiots
oh this Joshua Jess Jess no [ __ ] oh I
want to read one bloomery hunger yeah I
decide water I gift that much we talk
about Jess sometimes so like yeah no I
think safety in numbers and Jess
seriously I got Rachel guess this pretty
[ __ ] dead she had a hill oh I know
what that noise was that but it was Josh
why would Josh be crying like a girl he
wouldn't be if you didn't walked out of
the burning building
oh my god thank you why don't youwait
why don't youwait you sacks of [ __ ] what
terrorism question okay
okay I stop where they're doing
separating again do they move someone
oh my god is going to heal I'm just
talking about them all dead
it's getting to about where I wish they
would all die Sam your slogan told him
to go by themselves so she took my mic
no I've no idea what Mike would be even
it's this this is like the weirdest
thing the game is done typically
this is really strange
Josh [ __ ] no eyes look at them they're
put in a pit but they haven't it
stripped it you know has a sister he
looked kind of dead to me and they had
it stripped his skin
nobody would you show us a static you
what that's a really weird thing to do
climb away come on she knows she's not
in a rush
well I don't think she's gonna die it's
all maybe structure maybe Josh could die
could be the thing to make weed guess
what
jump let's jump down sorry let's do it
okay oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] okay good
good sake we landed and do it faster
yeah well I'll go faster save Josh okay
wait
because that's a problem well if he's in
your Lake when you go too fast once
those those things they come up faster
yeah makes a lot of like still like yeah
I'm a trainer poppin up yes
swear
alright I'll screw that up twice anyway
so she George could be done anyways he's
the best she's out but he was doing well
I think that we're going to save Josh
right now she doesn't want his head on
there oh is that okay well I guess I'm
doing that that's one once I wasn't
really sure if that was what I want to
do but this is my area as mojo she is
absolutely make sure that she had she
must've found a bit a watch so after
thinking about where I [ __ ] up with um
Mike I think there was no way that Mike
could have died trying to get to Jess
it's because he took too long so I'm
thinking there's no way that she can die
here because it's not about her it's
about Josh so the whole thing is just
like a test for uptick costing it to
Josh as fast as we can or at least
that's when we have talked myself into
everything false and potentially risk
Stan but oh absolutely how can I die sin
doesn't deserve to die
she's been coming knowing where I really
want Sam to live she's baked good knows
why this guide you want I'm not sure I
you know I don't know spirit
Oh
yeah okay yes
tuck it it's not yeah Josh
what